it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes that's a great story we'll pick it
up later okay welcome to movie fights
hash tag movie fights live I'm Hal
Rudnick I'll be your host today and we
have got so much fun in store for you
and helping us keep some law and order
around here and decide the battles etc
we got the Dan's let's go to the Dan cam
Dan Laurel I know what's going on in the
world of fact-checking oh how you don't
want to know no I'm ready to check all
of these facts heck yeah
listen to arguments make objective
decisions and ultimately be told that
I'm wrong I mean yeah the the comments
section can be it can be a harsh place
sometimes it can be forgiving no I met
my mom you're wrong going okay very
tough judge but do you know what tough
you know you responded to the tough love
yes sitting next to Dan we have the
delightful Danielle Radford oh wow
Danielle so let me quickly uh
let folks know about the some judging
stuff and then you can tell us what
you're going to be focusing on man yeah
so every argument dan and myself are
going to weigh in and if there's a tie
you guys decide and you will speak
through the delightful conduit that is
Daniel Radford Danielle take it from
there fill us in on what's going I am
the voice of the people house so the way
this is gonna work and I know that
people have been asking so we put it in
the description so click on the
description it will tell you exactly how
this is going to work but just so you
know you guys there's going to be a pull
YouTube only not Twitter although I will
be checking your comments and letting
y'all know which ones are funny so I
could try your best you know just like
do your best work I trust you but go
ahead and if you're looking for it when
it appears now the new poll question
isn't gonna start until the question has
been asked and some people have gone
through some stuff you go ahead you
click
the icon the live button it'll show you
the new poll if you're looking for like
updated results or the updated poll
you're like what's happening the trick
that I use is I go down to the gear and
I turn annotations on and off and that
kind of refreshes stuff for me it's
great
Danielle glad to have you there and also
you're gonna be on sick meme Patrol
right yeah talk some junk on Twitter and
maybe we'll give you a shout out during
the show and what a show it's going to
be we're gonna be talking Marvel we got
some other questions related to a
certain sporting event that's coming up
this weekend a lot of crap is gonna go
down let's meet today's competitors
first up he's a comedian and a writer
and you have seen him a lot on screen
junkies lately please make some noise
for ED Grier hi guys
plug something basically Edgar it
destroys for all your nearest snark
needs on Twitter and I'm also an artist
and you can check out my stuff on
Instagram nice so you're an artist you
do a commissioned work mostly just
chicks with guns it's a nice sub-genre
could you like draw a picture of like
Salma Hayek holding an ak-47 nice Oh
what about a Frida Kahlo holding an
ak-47 even more feminist yeah sick this
guy's a friend of the family you've seen
him on screen junkies many times they
also call him the master of the speed
round
it's boys and row boy good to be back
man
I'm excited I missed fighting I missed
using the weirdest knowledge in my brain
for good and not evil and that's good to
have an outlet for listening to Eminem
my whole life so here we are nice and we
through a Marvel question in there for
you because you are one of the hosts of
Marvel movie news when I close yeah you
can find out Tuesdays on popcorn talk we
do a live show all things Marvel from
all the studios public and Collider
sometimes I just love talking to comics
and I love the fans I love that the
Internet is so chock-full of comic love
right now like Black Panther comes out
so soon and it is gonna change
everything
not that I've seen it and loved it but I
see black families just it's such a
magical time to be a comic fan like we
we won there's a victory among nerds and
it's magical hell yeah I remember we had
you in when Deadpool was coming out and
your excitement got me excited and then
it took over the world yeah it has
changed r-rated like landscape it's just
it's a magical time guile yeah people
were cussing and eating chimichangas
hola and people have changed since hell
yes
there was a pegging scene in a major
motion picture role that package
[Music]
yeah oh wow so for those of you who are
rejoining us again for the first time
did that make any sense I don't know but
we have two fighters we have three
regular questions that again Dan and
myself will judge dannielle will be
holding it down on the tie breakers if
and when we need them after those three
questions we go to the speed round for
speed round questions where it's
anybody's ballgame
even if someone is down 3-0 you all can
come back if you sweep that speed around
coy are you ready ready
Edie how you feeling I feel like I
should go to the plug better let's do
this
first question what dead / retired MC
you villain should come back for one
more film and we're gonna start with coy
Chandra I'm going to start with the Holy
Trinity that does not get enough credit
the Iron Man films are glorious and
Marvel Captain America came back with a
big way with Winter Soldier and Civil
War but Iron Man set the bar and started
the MCU literally and in the beginning
of the MCU they started with the ten
rings they led up to the Mandarin and
then the Mandarin we got we got was the
most polarizing version possible I
personally like Ben Kingsley's Mandarin
I like the bait-and-switch but for the
entire hordes of internet that did not
I think the Mandarin deserves to come
back as the actual Mandarin I want a
Daniel Dae Kim Mandarin I want an actual
nefarious evil Mandarin that isn't a a
punch line I think it was a great way to
have the Mandarin relevant I think it
was great way too huge
older killing and make him worthwhile
but why not have him come back again and
have them as an emperor palpatine why
not have him come back as someone that's
been pulling the strings even more than
we thought why not have the ten rings we
set up in the first movie which were not
resolved in Iron Man 3 actually resolved
in the fourth film and give Iron Man his
Lex Luthor there's a reason that Iron
Monger felt just like Iron Man because
he was there's a reason whiplash felt
like Iron Man because he was and you
cannot have your best bill and breathe
fire and you cannot have a
bait-and-switch villain where it was
obvious they wanted the female villain
to be the female villain in the studio
decided no no Guy Pearce we haven't yet
had the perfect Iron Man film well we
have the perfect Iron Man with the
Mandarin we can
perfect Iron Man film with the perfect
Iron Man and bring back the one true
nemesis of Iron Man by having three
movies have set up and have your emperor
palpatine the Mandarin deserves a zone
movie deserve some mechanism Thank You
koi strong opening statements ed Grier
what do you got for us
I can't rebut that already I'm chomping
at the bit sore but I like it I'm okay
you know I've been on here before and
sometimes I come off like a jerk like I
know everything I'm just gonna dial it
back and tell you guys a couple things
that I believe Red Skull is my guy Red
Skull needs to come back because as you
can see much like Nazism itself Red
Skull you know to mean Red Skull
represents that and can represent that
and can get its face smashed in these
times where we really need some Nazis to
get their faces smashed he can be a good
proxy a minute Jack Jack Kirby in way a
good proxy for us and it's a nice
do-over because in the first movie they
try to divorce him from Nazism so they
could sell toys or whatever you know
they mean so they wouldn't have to put
swastikas on all his neat toys for
Christmas and and they divorced him from
that from that true blue origin
you know I'm Jan they divorced him from
that history which I don't think it's
cool I think what they did to bring him
back full nazi he comes back out of the
Cosmic Cube with a bunch of cool powers
super full nazi gets his ass stomped 300
million dollar movie you don't I mean
that's I want to see that and I think
America needs to see that and that's all
I'll say for now all right
good opening statements let's mix it up
you want to rebut rebut okay
the concept you know what this is the
one time that Marvel just threw the
entire history away for a character that
I actually agreed with it it was a
wonderful bait-and-switch by Shane Shane
black in Iron Man 3 and I don't think I
don't think we should undo that also the
Mandarin let's take out the whole iron
fisting thing that they did with Ben
Kingsley the first time they made an
Asian or their a Marshall Asia in the
sort of Asian II about a second anyway
anyway
the first time they made one of these
cultural appropriator characters that I
actually agreed with it I was like this
is so cool he's taking Eastern mysticism
and a little bit of the shadow and all
this garbage and and fake and oozed it
up and this in this weird way I thought
that was masterful and dismantle that I
think does an injustice so my my goal
would not to dismantle that's to further
that I love the idea as a
bait-and-switch that worked for the
audience but we never actually landed on
the villain in my opinion alderic
Kingsley Aldrich Killian wasn't the
Mandarin so I think we still haven't
seen the Mandarin my Mandarin be someone
we haven't met and that bait-and-switch
would remain and then we'd get the final
that would have all the Iron Man fans
had there come up and so I'm not erasing
any continuity I'm actually building on
continuity my problem with the Red Skull
is that he works really well in the past
but if you look at the Captain America
films the weakest of them is the First
Avenger because of the pacing because
the type of movie they had to make in my
opinion for bringing the Red Skull to
modern-day it doesn't work because of
that Red Skull was a great portrayal by
Hugo Weaving but if you're gonna have
him come back it's not for one film it's
for three this is for one more film if
you want to tell the Red Skull right you
have an arc you build up the Red Skull
that's the nemesis you can tell the
Mandarin in one film because we've had
three of building up to it we haven't
had a Red Skull that would land in
modern day without having to have a full
arc Captain America red skull with Lex
Luthor that's the way it works with the
Mandarin we've earned it so we can have
that final button the Red Skull needs
much more time to kind of retcon the
fact that yeah I oughta be but the fact
that he's earned it like I said it was a
nice it was like it was like a nice
Three's Company episode he didn't really
have ten rings it was just enough he
bangs broads this is crazy
max did a rewrite on the script yeah so
I mean I and for me that was quite
enough of the Mandarin in regards to
Hugo we've been coming back I I don't
agree that it would have to just be for
one movie even if it was for one movie
in that story he would be doing
something like he did and Nic Spencer's
hated run where with the cosmic you
powers Red Skull is remaking our
present-day reality into a more more
fascistic reality and we could take on
all those subjects and whatnot I believe
that that would be infinitely more
interesting than us trying really hard
not to not to fetishize Asian people it
with with a portrayal
a certain sort of you know sort of a
Ming Ming the Merciless avoiding that
would be to the main goal is to actually
have an Asian portrayal that wasn't
pandering that wasn't that was actually
the character and I think that we
haven't had a character in the Marvel
Universe that is that and I thought this
is more execution dependent though and
like you said the Red Skull was trapped
in a Rocketeer right I mean he was she
was trapped in he was trapped in The
Rocketeer if you will The Rocketeer of
movies which is lower than this is a war
absolutely era so III mean it's a Civil
War sort of aesthetic so what I'm saying
is to bring Red Skull into then they
made Zola the living computer cool he
was one of Rascals like a pitchman but
that's the same button but to bring Red
Skull what's it now I don't believe it
be infinitely easier to make him cool
than a little nebbishy guy inside a
computer would you still see a Hugo
Weaving playing Red Skull I could if
you'd be willing to do it it felt like
he wasn't Matt down I can certainly see
them recasting with a CGI face and a
cool guys voice yeah all they need the
boy since the Reds right and I would
love to see them to redo the skull
because once he comes out of the Cosmic
Cube he's put himself back together a
different way but disassembled we've
already like lost Hydra hydras not a
shell but it was if you're gonna bring
back the Red Skull you need it to be a
leader of a force and he comes back to a
world that's not his that's why you need
more than one movie my problem is Red
Skull can get some torches okay so who
would you see playing the Mandarin I
love Daniel Dae Kim I think he's
extremely underrated I think if he
doesn't play anymore he should play the
Mandarin and I think that it would
require a lot less backstory than fixing
the Red Skull and I think that it's a
movie that we deserve whereas the Red
Skull already lost Hydra we've already
had the three movies captain Merrick has
already arguably evolved past him and
we've lived this long without Charles
Xavier in the universe which was that
amazing run I like to we've lived this
long about these characters I think Red
Skull works better in comics than in
movies and I think the visual aesthetic
of Red Skull might not translate as well
the hard thing about mandarins we're
talking about that appropriation in that
conversation I think the Red Skull is a
very tricky
character visually to get right and I
think as long as you handle them
delicately the Mandarin can be right
because of that first movie that One
Ring gave us so much story forum can
land I want to land there we haven't yet
I want to ask you guys to put it in
layman's terms for comic book fans and
non comic book fans just give us again
the clear storyline that you'd want to
take from the comics and have your
villain follow or something you'd want
to interpret from the comics and put
into a movie
edy let's start um basically any sort of
pastiche like I want to get into the
minutiae of plot here you know there's a
reason why we're here instead of it uh
somewhere else okay so but I do believe
it would be very simple to take a
pastiche of some of the things that Ed
Brubaker has done with with Red Skull
especially red skulls incessant
obsession with the Cosmic Cube trying to
get it back together all those all those
different and like I said that there's
sort of a Jon Osterman thing that we
could do with Red Skull literally
putting himself back together over time
maybe maybe manifesting in certain ways
with that the Avengers see and they're
trying to counteract and they don't
really know what it is and then he pulls
himself molecule by molecule back
together through the power of the Cosmic
Cube and now we have a we can have a
thousand foot tall Red Skull if he wants
to be he could be what everyone's he's
like core vac for like old-school fans
sort of a Silver Surfer as a guy on a
couch type character because all this
powers within the Red Skull so to have
an ultimate to heaven to have a Nazi be
that in charge I can't imagine it oh
wait I can hahaha gotcha
and thank you and and koi in all three
Iron Man films he always solves the
problems with science and that is the
brilliance of Tony Stark Iron Man 3 he
goes through the entire film not in the
Iron Man suit because you can
scientifically solve these problems how
do you for a man that is more brilliant
than any other man you bring in
mysticism the Mandarin is a master of
mystic arts the likes of which Tony
Stark is I mean the likes of which like
dr. Strange's so you bring in someone
that is his equal but in another realm
where he can't hang so you make a movie
where you're seeing this guy trained
you're seeing all these underlings we've
had three films of people that work
under him so in the first film that big
bad is just a henchman with one ring the
second film we see him pulling the
strings the third film we have this
older guy that might be his second
lieutenant but someone that thinks he's
more important than he is and then boom
fourth film we find out who
actual mystic master is we meet the
Mandarin we sing that he's been
responsible for all of Tony Stark's
problems maybe he kills Pepper Potts
because at this point she's done with
her contract you know when a Paltrow's
out of the normal universe so we see how
powerful he is and then you have Tony
not being able to rely on science he has
to swallow his pride he has to call the
Avengers for the first time because in
all the movies they made it very clear
he's not a man that wants to do that we
have them have to backtrack in his Civil
War distinctions and we realized that he
is a team player and that is the end the
final arc for Tony Stark as long as
pride becoming a team player and having
to rally them together to take out the
Mandarin who's been doing all this from
the beginning
so are you pitching a full trilogy
between the Mandarin no it's just the
one film because we really trilogy is
already built in four so you throw three
flashbacks from three films you ready
have it allows you to have a quadrilogy
spirit of three oK you've got a really
angry fan standing in front of you
saying your guy's dead pull the rug out
from both your characters don't need to
see them see you as far past that how do
you respond to that koi my character has
not been met yet
my character is literally in propelled
team behind the scenes my guy is not
dead because he hasn't introduced the
concept of my guy is dead my guy is dead
only in the eye of the beholder my
character can't be dead because he does
not yet exist so therefore everything
we've seen is waiting for my character
to manifest they can't argue anything I
gotcha
edy respond to that angry fan my
character is it's not it's a classic
do-over which is what these movies are
entitled to our children are going to
watch different actors play every day
I'm body you don't I mean so so that
that's the point I'm making we deserve a
do-over on red skull because he was
trapped in a phantom zone of a film and
I I believed that if we apply current
supercooled Jason Bourne II aesthetics
to him and this new way the Marvel
Universe is is basically they know how
to make the sausage now is all I'm
saying
he was he's like that he's like one of
those old drawings of Bart Simpson what
the it's all up that's okay you
should heard Scott man slash the red
skull that we saw in the first adventure
was much like the Steamboat Willie you
know Mickey Mouse I think we deserve a
fully refined Mickey Mouse
you know that's what I believe and if
you pick one actor to play that would it
be Hugo Weaving or we talked a little
bit about it but if you're gonna have if
you can reboot it the way you want you
know what I'd like Clint Eastwood doing
a bad German accent no you know what I
really think you go wewe could do it
because I think that we would we where
we've mastered a way to CGI his face to
where it'll the consistent Skol effect
will be there without having to use
makeup so I think Hugo Weaving could
replies to reprise his role and do well
time wow are we here for both of these
combatants man what a battle you guys I
mean I felt like I was in between the
Mandarin and we won back yes these these
battles these arguments were both
fantastic
I mean coy I you were talking about not
getting full Mandarin and then Edie you
brought up us like kind of an underrated
argument that I really appreciate that
it was a great bait and switch that
there was that you know Shane Black was
having some fun with that script and you
both like schooled me on some
interesting tidbits and moments from the
comics and from these characters history
but I feel like it came down to ed you
were saying that we could kind of reboot
and reinvent this character and it sort
of washes away to an extent the Red
Skull in Captain America the First
Avenger where as you said we were kind
of building up to this moment with the
Mandarin and the way you were talking
about the Mandarin and the machinations
being the puppet master from behind the
scenes and then you teased a little bit
of Doctor Strange coming in perhaps
because that mysticism you might need
some mysticism to fight mysticism but
then you're brought in the present-day
politics which I really throw I got my
juices flowing
ah at the end of the day wow you stop
making this hard for me guys
at the end of the day though I feel like
the movie that is most in place to be
made is quois and I'm going 104 coy and
the Mandarin Dan Merle this is a very
tough decision factually it is true red
skulls comic book origins whereas a Nazi
then he was part of high jewelry as the
MCU they Hydra was a well depends on if
you go to agents of shield it's a
ancient cult also and you made this is a
semantic thing you referenced the Cosmic
Cube and the movies it's the tesseract
but it's the same general sense and
David Lee Kim ironically ironically
coincidentally has appeared in two non
MCU Marvel movies he was in Hulk Langley
and he was in spider-man 2 you were to
make this would not be the first Marvel
movie for him it would be the first MCU
movie for him this is a very difficult
decision I feel like you both had pluses
and minuses I thought that you both kind
of muddied your characters histories a
little bit where maybe there was some
chance to clean that up so it kind of
washes out on both of those points but I
think the most concise pitch that I
heard as far as where they fall into the
mythology of the character and how it
relates to the established mythology was
from koi so I'm gonna have to give this
one to koi as well and that means koi is
gonna get the point but Danielle I want
to hear about some craziness on social
media and what people voted so it looks
like going again on YouTube not on
Twitter I just feel like I need to keep
saying that yeah man
a lot of y'all were into the Mandarin
which was funny because like it came
from behind it was ruling let's go
and then you just argued your way into
that Mandarin a couple of the best
things that I saw first of all thank you
all for all the Parks and Rec gifs
please keep tagging
amazing they just keep it's like you
know the way to my heart
Jack Shipley at GRS pip-boy mm and I'm
good lord don't make me do that wrote
bring back thomas the train from ant-man
it's really good
look i'm up because there's a gift nice
yeah and then a lot of people just
giving me mandarin oranges QT oranges
which are all so adorable and great
mandarin oranges are not a villain you
know what the villain is scurvy they're
the solution yes they're the here Thank
You Danielle thank you for that thank
you for being on me and patrol and I'm
just like listening to the conversation
and Marvel headquarters we can't have
swastikas on our toys are flying off the
shelves as collectors items okay we got
104 koi let's see what the question is
for round number two Oh an honor of the
big game this weekend what's the best
football movie man how about it the big
game relapse a Super Bowl we said it
okay
best football movie we're gonna start
with Ed Grier okay I firmly acknowledge
how an unconventional my choices but my
choice is Shane Black's beautiful
screenplay
the last boy scout the last boy scout is
my favorite but look at oh my god well
look at David that's Pete Damon Wayans
there guys that's their guy's height of
powers oh my god
and
and as a semi peek you know Bruce Willis
but anyway the thing about glass Boy
Scout is much like the best shark movie
of all time
its jaws correct I'm glad you said
John's right 47 meters down okay the
bottom line is in that movie you hardly
ever see the shark but when you see the
shark it's very important it's very
important it's very important for the
plot it's very stirring and it's very
moving and that is the way that I would
like to or this that's a flavor of how
I'm gonna argue last Boy Scout as the
greatest football movie of time of all
time because it's really about the way
that I see football and that's what I'll
say okay all right intriguing koi
shan-dro best football movie of all time
I would like to argue the best problem
of real time is one that's about more
than football
it's about spirit it's about family it's
about bringing people together it's
about how horrendous racism is it's
about the glory that has Denzel
Washington I am of course talking about
we are them titans the mighty mighty
titans now Remember the Titans is a
movie you hear we are the Titans mighty
mighty Titans out of stuck in your head
for days the movie is so good that it
made Wayne Avista Pictures just rally
around sports films this is a movie that
had the Rudy moment with the kid getting
injured and rally behind and this is a
movie that had commentary on such
important subject matter that people in
you know perhaps the government today
should watch Remember the Titans this is
a movie about sports entertainment being
about more than just sports which is
what I think sports movies are about
sports movies are about more light I
agree with you sports movies are about
more than just the game it's about what
it does to people this is a movie that
made people rally together it's about
people that showed the problems in their
thought process this is a movie about
becoming a man and leading a team to
victory and it's about kids and it's
about overcoming adversity this movie
has so much in it that it doesn't need
any crazy high jinks it doesn't have any
crazy
explosions and I love Shane black as
much the next Hannah so I'm gonna say
the rebuttal cuz man it's gonna be hard
to talk badly about last Boy Scout but
when you're talking about a football
movie
there's a reason remember the titans
shine so bright and is an entire
generation sports movie Remember the
Titans is the one gentleman you both
have good kickoffs to miss argument to
play the rest of the first quarter okay
this is my thing about when you say that
it's it's about more than football that
kind of means it's not about football
boy scout is all about football because
the only reason why we care about these
pituitary cases slamming into each other
at high speed is because people gamble
on that and people watch it to the tune
of several billion dollars and to me
that my friend is what football is
actually about does this this this black
hand at white hand walking together into
CTE that you're selling me know I know I
don't get that if you're there walking
together to the concussion tent I'm just
saying it's just like ebony and ivory
laid up on a gurney like oh who cares
who cares to me a billion dollar
industry being taken down by a ragtag
bum and his and his ex black player
sidekick guy and then these are the kind
that shred and he throws the movie that
in its opening five seconds of
advertising shows a really cool football
shot and then pulls out a gun because it
doesn't have a sensationalize anything
so it pulls out a gimmick Shane black
made a really good movie right before
this called Lethal Weapon which was
actually about a great cop on the edge
and his partner then they're like what
if we have almost as good as Mel Gibson
who's with us because honestly that's a
Bruce Willis is and then you throw them
in with Damon Wayans that's I'm sorry
that's not Danny Glover you got two guys
that are the b-list versions of
characters written by the guy that
actually wrote the best good buddy cop
movie of all time then you throw a
football in it that is just that is just
a sad only the only thing Bruce Willis
is inferior to Mel Gibson hat is answer
machine tapes
[Laughter]
Gibson's can go for days he's got ease
he's got style Bruce Willis isn't great
answering machine tapes but he is good
at phoning it in yeah so my problem the
last Boy Scout is it was a great way to
make an action movie and throw in a
gimmick and the whole movie feels like a
gimmick for me the last boy's got is a
movie that involves football only as
like what's that sport that is relevant
today that we can make gambling about oh
okay football where as Remember the
Titans is about the opposite for me
Remember the Titans uses football as a
way to attract audiences that wouldn't
normally watch a movie about such
importance um well I mean I I do love
the fact that it is selling generation
after generation on getting slammed into
for the profit of the ultra-rich I
understand it as high school grown-up
high school I'm just saying I just don't
I don't like that as like this civil
rights as a poison pill to indoctrinate
people about yeah I get it but did you
sprinkle some stuff you sprinkle some
civil rights are basically concussion
the story yeah I just don't I just don't
like it I don't I don't like the way
it's heading and I don't like the fact
that that so much emphasis was put on
sports in that way I love the fact
though that people think about all the
blindside II let's hold hands stuff
about sports but last boyscout really
pounded at home what is this about the
New Age gladiators what they do to their
bodies no one cares about what they do
to their minds nobody cares about nobody
cares about their lives outside of it
but we all root with our Cheetos and
ours in our sleeves you know to me we
all root for them when we drink our
Pepsi's and we watch them destroy
themselves
so you're saying what last Boy Scout is
about and that is what football is about
just making sure I want to wrap my head
around your argument are you saying that
last Boy Scout has more of a cynical
take on football and it deconstructs you
could say cynical you could say
realistic you guess you could say a lot
of words but they made a movie about
that called cushon that did it better
Will Smith concussion was a movie about
that with the science tobacco the truth
he did not do a good African acts
we're talking about concussion but yeah
Will Smith in concussion it's not a
conversation that needs me but
concussion itself is handling those
things in a movie that doesn't need the
gimmicks and the glamour and the pizzazz
last Boy Scout just didn't have anything
except pop where's for me or one of the
Titans I understand what you're saying
about like ebony and ivory and that in
that movie being that but it's Denzel
Washington ascending into peak Denzel
Washington is Denzel Washington
delivering these powerhouse speeches cuz
the one thing you watch football movies
for is that big coach speech and you
cannot argue that Denzel Washington's
big coach btrim the Titans not the best
and at the same time you get like baby
Ryan Gosling you get Ethan SU play and a
great performance well you get like
people that are in this movie that
turned into mega stars at the beginning
of their ascension and there's a reason
that all these people became stars is
because of Remember the Titans showing
the world that it's more than just a
sports movie it's a movie about people
be it like I said I I do get that and I
respect that and I'm not quite as
cynical as I'm coming on I just agree
with myself that that last Boy Scout is
just as a way to examine a sport
especially in the era last Boy Scout
comes from you think you could make last
boys you could make last Boy Scout right
now they would they would do all kinds
of stuff to it they'd have that they'd
have the rock and he'd be you know to me
playing both leads right yeah to fight
some guys gentlemen okay for your
closing arguments I want you each to
deliver it like you are an Al Pacino
style football coach in any given Sunday
I want you to rally everyone and to get
a stirring in our loins that's the only
thing I could think of not that's the
wrong thing to say but get us stirred in
our hearts and souls and Edie we're
gonna start with you you're a football
coach go gentlemen
we got a rally around this movie
we got a rally around this fighter ed
green he's getting the drubbing it looks
like he's gonna lose another one he's
the most decorated funniest jobber in
movie fights this is nuts
so what I'm gonna need you guys to do is
March our asses out on that field damn
the plays don't even wear helmets freak
them out just run out there and kick
some ass forehead all right because if
he loses this if he loses this round no
one's going to Chuck E Cheese Wow whoo
man that is good stuff John Breaux give
us some closing thoughts in a football
coach I'm a gentleman
Michael idea spent a long time Cummings
in a rough season you need to understand
that the movie I'm talking about
represents more than just cinema more
than just buena vista more than just
disney and they're paying the check so I
mean you gotta understand this movie
represents the betterment of mankind and
many many people that watch sports
aren't always about the betterment of
mankind so we're tricking them you see
what we're doing it's a bait and switch
much like the Mandarin and Iron Man 3
we're making them think that they're
watching a sports movie but we're
actually using Denzel to preach hey love
your brother doesn't matter what color
he is hey love sports because we all
love sports hey some people are better
at sports and other people maybe that's
okay and what I'm saying is watch sports
you can all band together you become a
family and what you guys are is a family
so I need you as a family to represent
me and make we are the Titans the mighty
mighty Titans the cold arms for football
movies forever
hoorah Wow all right let's hear it for a
bollock of these combatants let's go
ahead and start with our man dan the man
Merle I mean I know Ed's coach felt as
if he was letting it down but he he
pointed something out early in the fight
that I kept an ear out for the entire
rest of the fight and he was right and
coy never really entered it he said you
mentioned everything in your argument
about this movie except for football and
coy did MIT he argued for every aspect
of his movie except for football there
was no it's the best football movie and
it was a great movie though togetherness
and Brotherhood and Denzel and his great
performance but Edie to me
sold why his movie was the best football
movie it was about people you know the
economy and these guys in the corruption
and money and gambling it's like maybe
it's not the most positive in the world
but he's so why it was the best movie
about football so I'm gonna go with Edie
BAM that's 104 Edie yeah you bring up
that's a really interesting point
because I'm looking at some of the notes
I wrote down and yeah coy mentions
spirit family racism Denzel but I feel
like it's inherent it is about a
football team so you're talking about
the quality of the movie but then I
thought added some great points about
the manipulative nature of certain films
where like you just like you turn it you
know into basically you know this
hallmark story of like you know a black
hand and a white hand holding hands and
walking off into the sunset which I I
think it's a nice image but yeah you had
to you had a lot of great points that
made me think about those motifs and are
they overuse are they just in
intentionally manipulative but you had
some really excellent points about
lethal weapon about shame black found
the composition that movie you know and
is it a lesser shame black effort and in
turn is it not the best football movie
and you really started to win me over
with that so for that and the fact that
you celebrated so many great things
about your film and you took down his
choice effectively I'm gonna go with coy
and send it to Danielle for the
tie-breaking vote
yike okay
well um this one is for earlier decisive
folks really like the Titans and they
would like us to remember them
it was 63% for Remember the Titans 36%
for the last Boy Scout I will say ed you
did wind up like that gap was way bigger
gap a few notes from the social medias
most of you very proudly don't know
football movies there were a lot of
Friday Night Lights references and just
by reading them I know that you watch
the show and not the movie any given
Sunday which is great cuz it's also my I
like that movie my personal favorite
well movie because people asked is the
program there is a huge discussion about
whether or not soccer or American
football is what we're talking about and
guys come on
I mean been denying as we connected the
question to the suit so we're obviously
talking about soccer talking about
American American football I'll also
mention a movie called North Dallas 40
from the 1970s with Nick Nolte great
gritty old football movie awesome and
what about one of the best football
movies around Dark Knight Rises with
your argument like a round like that I
almost did any given Sunday just to be
like really pedantic but come on I mean
he's got to do a patina like the dog bow
but knows basketball but know everything
I won really good point we got was from
at captain lot so the best football
movie is about more than just football
it's of our family respect and growing
as a man and he picked the garbage
picking field kicking Philadelphia
phenomena which is a Disney movies
starting Tony Danza which I am not sure
if it's real or not I'm just assuming it
isn't
I can't possibly that is real no yeah
amazing it's uh what is it I don't even
know what it is it's a TV show
thanks on the fast track thank you for
that and thank you
football fans now it's time for round
three okay boys up to zero but it's uh
any man's game oh my god it's a blind
bye that's a gift okay
it's a blind fight you guys I'm gonna
ask you a question and then first one to
then respond with your answers for this
blind fight coy Edie
please pick any character from an
animated movie
the genie
Bugs Bunny great unlikely bedfellows
mm-hmm Wow the genie and you are picking
the genie from the movie Aladdin
maybe there's another but hopefully
sorry and I assume Bugs Bunny's been in
movies right before any of that Warner
Brothers movie yes ring okay here is
your question which animated character
would be the ultimate survivor in the
purge animated character would be the
ultimate survivor in the purge koi
you're starting us off for round numero
tres now I will not lead with the
obvious of I have three wishes so
they're in I can wish away the purge
because that just seems unfair
I will lean into the fact that I have
the genie that can grant me any number
of things to help me survive the purge
so I if I cannot in this universe grant
myself out of it I can get any supplies
I have a great friend this guy is the
best
he's funny so if I'm hiding out for
months at a time I have entertainment
he's a great guy that like only wants
what's best for me
because he knows I'm gonna free him at
the end there's no argument there like
the genie knows we're homies so I'm
definitely gonna free him at the end of
this purge slashed three witches I'm in
a situation where I'm hanging out with
Robin Williams which makes me very happy
just in general I'm in a situation where
I've got an all-powerful deity on my
side so there is no one that's gonna
want to mess with me I'm in the purge
I want gun power I want strength I also
want polarity and entertainment and
compassion and I got the genie so I feel
like I'm gonna get handsome
all right opening salvo for the genie
Edie let's talk about bugs look man this
is this is no contest this seems like a
gift from heaven because Bugs Bunny is
the ultimate survivor so kids are
chasing you down an alley they're
chasing bugs went down alley all of a
sudden there's a hot sexy lady down
there
and they're like dumbfounded by this hot
sexy lady and then she puts their head
in a waffle iron press here I mean it's
just an unbeatable you talk about and
I'd like to clarify are you the genie or
are you the dude with with the lamp
because if you hate if you've pledged to
not use your wishes to get out of the
purge I'm gonna make Bugs Bunny will
make you use three wishes on all the
chainsaw he's dropping on you if you are
the genie
[Music]
all right
blind fight.i one of my wishes would be
that Bugs Bunny never gets to animate
anything of himself so he is stuck as a
mere rabbit no dresses no guns no
fingers to solve things Bugs Bunny is
just a mere rabbit so he can use all of
his repertoire of ingenious ideas but
without any assistance so bugs is
trapped in a pre tricky situation
because he's basically someone in Who
Framed Roger Rabbit that doesn't have
any any any ground okay well my well my
well-thought-out
rebuttal to that is boo even as even as
a mere rabbit I'm still a cartoon rabbit
baby and I can I can did all I know is
if you started coming after me and I was
in the purge I would just as Bugs Bunny
go down wherever he goes in that hole
and come back with all the travel stamps
on my suitcase and be like whoo
I have acid that purge baby you don't
mean so even as a cartoon rabbit I'll do
some water ship down baby
we can do this as a regular rabbit I'll
still take it down boy
so I think as a genie not only Genie not
only to have 24 hours to deal with
whatever I can I can have a great old
time doing it genie gives me three
wishes I only need to use one of them I
become a prince and I just lock
everything up for 24 hours
rich people tend to survive the purge
some howl I mean that's the world we're
living in so I would have the genie just
grant me that and I'm good I'm cozy
there's no stakes with the genie cuz I'm
just said I'm good the rabbit is still a
guy that can get hurt you I'm just I
need I reiterate you're in your house
you've got all the perch blinders down
as it were okay and you lay down next to
your wife your beautiful sexy wife I'm
not sure how this is winning it's just
tearing mind I'm haunted PTSD solutions
you always worry about the fact that
Bugs Bunny puts himself first so we're
gonna go logic we're gonna go like basis
on this if I'm teaming up with Bugs
Bunny I'm worried about bugs bunny
self-serving so Bugs Bunny and you were
the last two people in a room Bugs
Bunny's gonna save his own ass he's Bugs
Bunny the genie is my homie
we got three wishes one bonded together
I'm saving with that last one I got two
wishes with my boy where his bugs he'll
betray he'll survive the purge I
wouldn't want to risk it hmm I think
we've bonded it's fine yeah all right
let's call it right there wow that was
the weirdest fun I've been a part of my
mom did yeah that was what what if what
a frightening what a frightening episode
of Looney Tunes that would be you know I
mean it's you know and I think like it's
what the genie like he could wish
himself out he's all-powerful so yeah
I'm sorry I didn't think you had a
chance until coy this guy got into how
wily
I don't trust him like what what a
frightening you get into bed with your
wife Edie for my money
you just won an unwinnable battle I give
one I get my point to Ed for that Bugs
Bunny - CooCoo Dan this fight was like
watching a Bugs Bunny carting his
fingers in the barrel everything you
can't draw things you can't be a butt ok
then I'll just dig into the group how
can you not give it to ya gotta give it
and like everything had brought up that
was like cannon like the genie but okay
yeah well earned point for that Danielle
what's going on on the socials oh yeah
um everybody is very Pro bugs it was
nine bugs 20% Genie that isn't even a
percentage that makes sense
one percent of people who buzz lightyear
someone else somehow one percent with
the buzz a couple of things of note a
lot of people were like yeah bugs is
like super violent obviously he would
win also it turns out a lot of you even
figured out how much I love cookies and
keep trying to send me corgis so I will
talk about Danielle and the Queen they
love corgis you know I expected the next
movie face it's just gonna be a bunch of
like gifs of like Sasha banks it's fine
NIC director on Twitter put Sud has been
trying to bird purge bugs for years
which I really liked
and then at Troy Loxton wrote I picked
Superman's mouth this best anime dove
care
the little baby moustache mouth I get it
you're funnier this money just dark it's
just dark too soon too soon if we just
experienced heart is broken don't do
this to me
alright wow it is 2 to 1 in favor of koi
but it is anybody's game going into the
speed round it's a little reminder of
the speed round rules
so it's 2-1 first player to 4 wins okay
we have 4 potential speed round
questions here and they each each player
gets 20 seconds to stage an initial
argument then a 10 second rebuttal they
each get a 10 second rebuttal and when I
ask a question the first person I hear
that person will go first the other
person will go second obviously and you
fill in it film Bugsy and baby let's do
it
koi have you done some all of the
cocaine you do but find a speed pair
okay
all right boys drug free love you yes we
did we do extensive testing all right
it's like the NFL jte roll that package
just kidding there's no package alright
first speed round question other than
Mario what classic Nintendo game would
make the best animated movie so heard
Legend of Zelda
all right duck hunt duck hunt hmm all
right we got Zil de ver stuck hunt
we heard koi first 20 seconds on the
clock for clay Chandra own opinion of a
magical fantasy world you have a female
lead which is more more required
especially animated film I want to take
you on a journey through every level of
puzzle making and solving to make kids
smarter I want to take you on a journey
with a movie that would make kids want
to think want to solve once you have
magical adventures and it's outside your
medieval times it's Lord of the Rings
but for kids it's Game of Thrones with
Riggins and it's like who doesn't love
link this is fun it's got great dialogue
it's got beautiful imagery the enemies
of time 20 seconds start whenever you
speak in a post-apocalyptic world where
ducks have taken over you and a lonely
band of dudes with buckshot are the only
thing between us and a foul existence
duck hunt 2019 summer that's all right
rebuttal Todd con is that it looks the
same in animations you already have the
game and wouldn't last very long it'd be
a good 20 minutes but I want a movie and
if I want to movie I want a full story
in Zelda's ports right that someone does
in the movie yet we need a movie and
made his way to go through the budget
restrictions I want to the movies as the
desperate get in a post-apocalyptic
movie we don't even remember if zelda
was the guy or the princess
whoa there is damn Wow
okay I mean you guys both came out of
there guns blazing and coy I mean I you
said so many words
Zelda yes and you paint a picture of
like you know the like I don't know I
wasn't as into the puzzles I was sold me
on this day how's he gonna do it
post-apocalyptic and then you put like
the foul existence in there sick puns
I'm all about sick puns I'm gonna give
one to Edie
Danielle talk to us let us know your
thoughts um III while I appreciate that
coy is the six from blossom of movie
fights as
it was also a fast talker who has been
told they need to slow all the way now I
am on Team stick puns I got to give it
to Ed damn Eddie takes this one dan any
facts you want to throw at us
Rizzo although I think that I was also
all right give the lady Wow
we got a hell of a ballgame here cuz
we're locked up at 2-2 here's your next
question this one's a doozy after black
panther what other famous cat should
chadwick boseman play grumpy
hmm okay sorry that was great ray do you
know what I think I'll go with
Heathcliff Heathcliff all right
we have grumpy cat versus Heathcliff the
cat coy you spoke first 20 seconds begin
whenever you speak Studios are all
trying to find a new IP what better way
than actually make a meme into a movie
that have chadwick boseman a brilliant
actor bring gravitas and power behind
grumpy cat the face that launched a
thousand memes as portrayed by an actor
that can make him relevant and
worthwhile the only man I would see
portray such an important cat is
chadwick boseman he brings such power to
the role such powerful voice and that
cat can do everything right Edie 20
seconds begin whenever you speak
Heathcliff's black man okay he's kicking
it at the junkyard with his homies his
girlfriend is so hot so hot with the leg
warmers man like I just feel like I just
feel like Heathcliff oh wait now he's
got that well he's got no his girls
thick he's black come on man sandwich
alright ten second rebuttal I'd take it
to him in a movie of that but I want a
full movie where I experience the
adventures Allah air but I want to see
an Air Bud with grumpy cat voice by
Chadwick Boseman
and jump again deserves Chadwick Boseman
we need that character and he's probably
black to time I just want to see a cool
black cat in the junkyard having fun you
know and picking up broads even though
you're in the junkyard I mean that's
game I mean again this is this is I
think this is a slam dunk guys Chadwick
Boseman
time Wow Wow
I don't know that's that
I think it's the gravitas of chadwick
boseman that he would bring to grumpycat
perhaps brought pushing it over the edge
so I'll go with koi 100 okay well I'm
gonna fact-check this for a second
graphic cat's a lady Oh is she
her name's tartar sauce hey but - but
worldly basically let's on the arguments
I just wanted to put that out there
grumpy cat tartar sauce she's the most
famous lady cat of most of time as much
as I loved the idea of a grumpy cat I
too want to see Heathcliff just like
hanging out a junkyard making it work
pick it up thick women nice okay it's
1:1 Wow okay so I mean you you really
had something with the gravitas if you
want it like at and chadwick boseman
he's done that not just with black
panther but with Jackie Robinson
they were good martial and but you know
what you had something like a really
cool angle on that saying Heathcliff is
a black man lives in a junkyard
I mean you reminded me of one of my
favorite sitcom characters of all times
Redd Foxx he was a junkyard man himself
oh hell yeah great song San Fran son is
a classic but then coy you came back
with trying to pull the rug out from
under Eddie saying I go with a 10-minute
movie but I want an epic of grumpy cat
like where is there 10 minutes of
material and grumpy can bond with grumpy
cat I don't know I don't think you laid
it out for me
twice that I just like like ten minutes
but you're talking about a mean like me
so that didn't work for me I owe you you
brought some gravitas to it but I gotta
give the point to Ed so we are at three
two and three to ed
woo go into the third question of this
speed round what a great moment in
sports here we go
what two movie stars should be the new
men in black what two movie stars new
men in black we're all giggles no
answers Oh Bryan Cranston and Dwayne the
rock Johnson five Nick Offerman and
Michael B Jordan okay Cranston and the
rock okay and hurt you first so the time
begins whenever you speak I do believe
it would be interesting to do men in
black with Dwayne the rock Johnson and
Bryan Cranston and you could do it
either way have the rock we the
experienced agent and Bryan Cranston
stumbling into this job after being a
teacher and doing meth or whatever
there's so many different ways you can
do it or you can flip flip the roles but
either way
The Rock's physical strength would be
tempered by Cranston's gravitas as you
said coy the thing that makes men in
black work is the grizzled old and the
new rookie Michael B Jordan playing the
rookie Will Smith part and then Nick
Offerman's voice just just upset and
dealing with Michael B Jordan it's got
all the levels of the old men in black
which is what makes it not 21 jumps
through it makes it not that movie that
the rock did with Kevin Hart
the rock makes the rock movies he
doesn't make other movies I don't want
this to be a rock movie I want this to
be men in black and I want to be in a
BAP tation ten second rebuttal
I like that you mentioned that crummy
movies such a lot elegance because I do
believe this would be a nice do-over of
that in that he would be an experienced
agent and and I do believes Cranston
would play a scientist that has drafted
into working with him in and black
Jumanji was the do-over and it was great
I made all the money the problem with
men and black is that you need that
dynamic it's the lethal weapon dynamic
and that's why I Nick Hoffman Michael B
Jordan are the only two they can make
that work he is K and he is J and that
some of you actually really want to see
you know I thought about it and I buy it
Wow how about it let's start with Daniel
Radford Oh I you know I have not been
super pumped on the idea of this reboot
but I would literally watch both of
these movies if they want something
different in work men and black and I
loved your arguments but as soon as coy
said lethal weapon dynamic I was like
yeah so I got to give this one to coy
yeah okay
oh and for the record coy needs to take
this to send it into our final sudden
death question he needs this to keep the
game going dan I would also I think give
it's a Koi ed was pitching Walter White
which I think Bryan Cranston is the
dynamic I was more excited about I had a
better idea of the movie I am going with
coin yeah all right coy takes the point
after this question one of you will walk
home a winner one of you will walk home
a loser by the way why are you both
walking home okay great battle for both
of you this has been a great movie
fights and here is our final question
for all the marbles what Star Wars
supporting character would make the
worst spin-off ever Akbar well Oh God
wedge
when we have akbar verse wedge and you
spoke first 20 seconds begin whenever
you speak it when did sillies die so i
alright alright something so I guess
that might be the reason why that would
be but arrow Akbar under the sea as a
weird submarine captain drafted into a
war he doesn't understand and then he
rises up the ranks he swims up the ranks
if you will come on that's awful that's
like the worst type of procedural
underwater military procedural more
careful Disney age is not only easy
someone that died you're supposed to
feel her his name is wedge throughout
the movie are supposed to rally behind
the guy named wedge the guy's name is
wedgie you're supposed to be like oh
this is our leader this is a military
commander named wedge they try to make
it cool it wouldn't work it'd be painful
and we've seen enough Thai fighter ask
movies x-wing we've seen it we've had it
that at least is different interesting
plus it's a traps iconic time ten-second
rebuttals I mean realistically that
Arabic bar show would be the worst thing
ever that I'm trapped at are terrible
series yeah it's it would be the worst
thing you ever saw and they tried to
sell my Akbar toys wedge antilles is
remembered fondly only because of his
friendship they tried to make a movie
about it would be a betrayal of the
legacy of the character and that's what
they might do and that's why I don't
want this to happen wedge forever issue
don't make a move time Wow okay Dan
Merle hmm talk to us this is very
difficult I mean half of quois argument
was about his name there's a guy named
Chewie loved him name is chewy yeah so
that doesn't really strike for me and I
needed like if added come back like guns
blazing and like he would have taken it
for me easily but I guess I have to go
down to how they describe their movies
for me and it's like what I rather would
it be a worst movie to see the TIE
fighter movie or would it be a worst
movie for me to see the underwater
creature procedural
guess it's that one so I guess Edie but
it's a the player in me is coming out
here how no I appreciate I appreciate
your feelings about the arguments your
stupid Chino so early I'm gonna go to
Danielle Radford yeah those were
literally the same notes I wrote mine oh
my notes were literally coy wedge
terrible name too many Thai fighters
portrayal of legacy of the character and
that was a great argument IDI Akbar
under the sea adventurer worst kind of
procedural bad toys so looking at or
word to performer Bert yes and under the
sea procedural will be the worst
I hate procedurals I have to say
portrayal of the legacy of the character
is a stronger argument against form
someone with going blue is one one so
comes down here to me so yeah I echo a
lot of the points we heard over there
yeah I think we got caught up a little
semantics said it would be a terrible
series at one point about just like a
spin-off movie but yeah again I got
really hung up there wasn't enough about
the like the the whole first argument
was just about the name wedge and that
like for me like that that twenty
seconds or so was kind of moot because
it's like the name doesn't matter
so if I'm taking the sum of the rest of
the parts of the arguments I feel like
Edie took it and Edie takes movie fights
today
Wow we're you just want movie bikes what
are you gonna do next
really good
I'm it's a pleasure to share the stage
with this guy yeah was a fun it was a
pleasure to be right here in the middle
of both of you
worthy combatants oh pretty yes go ahead
and plug some okay take two of the
plugs Bailey you know my podcast nerd
goat it's it's really cool it's on the
bill Bonds network and we talk to people
about their favorite fictional character
of all time I'd love to have you on ah
and it's it's a podcast that's growing
and now we're opening a patreon and
everything it's really cool so it's
called nerd goat podcast never go to
podcast comm check that out hell yeah
thank you sir coy you were awesome today
please tell us something that's going on
with you dibs on Deadpool or Tyler
Durden one of those two okay I host
Marvel movie news for popcorn talk I do
my own show which is the Institute where
I basically review whatever I'm enjoying
so I think the Internet should be or
force of positivity so I talk about
things I love so movies TV books and
experience and if you guys take their
suggestions I will I will review it so
in my Instagram is literally just tons
of videos of me talking very fast for a
minute so if you like speed around
that's kind of what inspired it so I
enjoy talking with ceiling fresh so my
Instagram is that and I love this format
man I I enjoyed the speed round so much
and like this weird banter of stuff you
don't have any place to you I think I'll
second that because I see a lot of
scuttlebutt about making you fun and do
some selling this everybody got to
talk yeah can I argue Genie versus Bugs
Bunny and don't miss it can I win a
fight with the Mandarin over the Red
Skull yeah so what a magical hell yeah
you're both excellent Stan marrow tell
us something that's going on
who could have an how could they have
rigged this game
and for speed round questions we don't
know really I wish I could post just
like rigs we have a whole second show
here how we just get to watch things
going by it's a good time for everybody
conspiracy theories behind movie fights
hey I August and I know that so many
people did we need a third option
besides the genie and Bugs Bunny I don't
think so I hope that people are
adjusting to the new format and this is
a great fight this hilarious and I look
forward to another fun one next week
hell thanks Dan
Danielle yep this was fantastic this was
such a good fight but funny kind of
already is like a genie he's like a
magical trickster and like right like
sorry I almost want like full-on Greek
theater nerd for you the fans but yeah
so uh yeah this was a great fight both
really good fighters I can't wait to see
both y'all back and doing more fighting
the fight against Shane Black today that
was so hard my love of Shane black I
mean you said Lethal Weapon like that
made me so happy that I'm not the only
legal weapon laughs so that was and red
skull was on my fix to make this hinged
on me thinking hard after you said genie
[Laughter]
you know it paid off and I want to thank
you guys for being a part of the good
times thank you for watching I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at Hal Rudnick and I want to
thank jte and Billy biz in the booth
thank you to the dance and thank you to
our competitors again bye everybody bye
bye
you